the legalization of medicinal cannabis
in 2018 should have provided relief to
thousands like andrew who rely on it
but costly private prescriptions mean
access is still a major problem and the
fear of being found in possession of the
drug by police is still rife it started
with
feeling
we've we're finally here we're finally
being recognized
to to still being in this position i am
today where i'm still having to get my
medication
through
the route that i don't want to be going
through without it sounding too drastic
um
i don't think i would be here to be
honest with you if if i didn't have that
tool in my box
to be able to use and i know that sounds
drastic and it will sound drastic to a
lot of people but no that is the truth
after being arrested and having his
medication confiscated multiple times
andrew now carries a can card it has my
information on it's got my photograph on
it a type of id requiring medical
evidence from a gp which proves he's
eligible to use cannabis for health
reasons
since its rollout last year can card has
prevented nearly one and a half thousand
people from being criminalized but its
founder says it's not a long-term
solution i'm actually running an
organisation that i wish didn't have to
exist
um
i really want there to be better access
to medicinal cannabis at
a good price with really good quality
for patients in the uk at the moment
that isn't going to happen easily in the
meantime can card continues to help in
the policing of cannabis the important
bit from a police in perspective is we
don't want to criminalise people we
shouldn't be criminalising yes we need
to enforce the law around the possession
of cannabis because it's illegal but we
ultimately want to make sure that
individuals can access mississippi
cannabis where clearly there is a health
need
having experienced decades filled with
challenges andrew hopes the barriers
that he and so many others continue to
face around medicinal cannabis will be
broken down sooner rather than later
aisha zarhidsky news